[Musique]
la voici la belle marie belles
merveilles d'être riz qui fait qu'on
fait c'est au soleil quoique l'âge
passait raconte que du ciel depuis
qu'ils y monte le vin jamais rien de
pareil dans cette ode à la reine sur sa
bienvenue en france le poète françois
malherbe célèbre l'arrivée en lançant de
la florentine marie de médicis seconde
épouse du roi henri iv
mariée au premier bourbon pour renflouer
les caisses de l'état
après les guerres de religion qui ont
dévasté le royaume de france
celle que les mauvaises langues surnomme
la grosse banquière demeure une reine
honnis par histoire devenue régente en
610 après l'assassinât d'henri iv
durant la minorité de son fils louis
xiii marie de médicis se laisse
manipuler par ces ambitieux favorise
italien concino concini et la galigaï
qui vont ternir pour des siècles sa
réputation
marie-mai dcc chassé du pouvoir en 1617
par son propre fils qu'elle jugé inapte
à gouverner c'est une reine en quête de
légitimité
elle n'aura de cesse d'intriguer contre
louis xiii depuis son exil forcé au
château de blois la reine-mère
entreprend alors une guerre féroce
contre louis xiii
arpentant les champs de bataille dans la
poudre de 100 jusqu'à sa cuisante
défaite aux ponts de cé en 16 120 qui
consacre une brève réconciliation entre
la mère et le fils
marie de médicis revient en grâce et au
conseil royal
par l'entremise de richelieu mais celui
qui fut sa créature et qu'elle avait
hissé sur le siège de cardinal puis sur
celui très convoité de principal
ministre est devenu trop puissant à son
goût la journée des dupes en 16 130 voix
l'éviction définitive de la reine mère
assigné à résidence à compiègne avant de
partir pour un ultime exil aux pays bas
espagnols la reine déchue ne reverra
jamais
france
[Musique]
marie voit le jour en 15 173 au sein de
la richissime famille médicis banquiers
des rois et des papes les médicis ont
érigé grâce à leur fortune
une véritable dynastie qui règne sur
florence depuis quatorze 134 elle est
originaire de florence comme son nom
évidemment le laisse penser
elle est la fille d'un grand duc de
toscane et sa mère se trouve être de la
branche des habsbourg sa mère
l'archiduchesse jeunes d'autriche meurt
en 15 100 78 laissant l'éducation de ses
enfants à son époux françois marie
premier de médicis le grand duc de
toscane
mais ce dernier profite de l'aubaine
pour épouse et sa sulfureuse maîtresse
bianca capello et délaisse ses enfants
[Musique]
marie reçoit une éducation humaniste de
princesse au palais pitti de florence
elle est confiée aux bons soins d'une
part entre francesca orsini qui lui
inculque que la piété et la discrétion
la jeune fille tombe alors éperdument
amoureuse du fils de sa préceptrice
virginio élevé à son côté la princesse
montre de grandes aptitudes en
mathématiques en chimie et en botanique
elle pratique aussi avec ardeur le
dessin la sculpture la gravure et l
excellent musique mais la mésalliance de
son père suscite une grande jalousie de
la part de marie de médicis envers sa
belle-mère elle la considère comme une
vulgaire fille publique et dont elle
doit supporter la présence humiliante à
la cour de toscane à cette époque on lui
attache les services d'une jeune fille
pétillante et particulièrement
intelligente
leonora daury de naissance à certaines
et de cinq ans son aîné l'histoire
retiendra la femme troublée
manipulatrice qu'elle va devenir sous le
nom de galigaï mais pour l'heure les
deux jeunes filles nous tue une profonde
amitié et marie prend conseil auprès de
leonora en toutes circonstances en 15
187 le grand duc et son épouse meurent
tous deux dans des circonstances
particulièrement troublante des rumeurs
d'empoisonnement bruisse bientôt dans
les couloirs du palais pitti ferdinand
le frère cadet du grand-duc renonce à la
pourpre cardinalice pour assurer la
succession
marie est une jeune fille classieuse au
teint éclatant et à l'abondante
chevelure blonde
d'abord le médicis son richissime la
princesse de toscane est un très beau
party et de prestigieux prétendants se
bousculent bientôt devant celle qu'on
surnomme la petite fiancée de l'europe
on envisage une union avec le duc de
parme
alexandre farnèse
puis avec l'illustrent duc de bragance
héritier d'une ancienne famille régnante
du portugal mais ça ne plaît pas
beaucoup parce que le portugal n'est
qu'un petit royaume sous la coupe de
l'espagne on envisage aussi un mariage
avec l'archiduc mathias héritiers de l'
empire ce qui flatte beaucoup le nouveau
grand duc de toscane
l'oncle de marie et enfin se dessine une
union avec le puissant prince de
vaudémont les négociations prennent une
tournure favorable qu'en surprise marie
de médicis à l'audace de refuser la
proposition de mariage
influencé par une vague prédiction d'une
religieuse de sienne nommé l'a pas cité
à qui lui avait révélé qu'elle serait
reine marie s'obstine alors à refuser
tout mariage autre fut royal mais la
princesse de toscane va devoir attendre
de nombreuses années avant que cette
prédiction se réalise
à 27 ans marie de médicis n'est toujours
pas mariée
[Musique]
en 15 189 le royaume de france est en
pleine guerre de religion henri iii
dernier roi de la dynastie des valois et
d'assassiner avant de mourir il désigne
son cousin bourbon le huguenot henri de
navarre pour lui succéder sous le nom
d'henri iv à la mort d'henri iii
effectivement les français se réveillent
avec un souverain qui a une religion qui
n'est pas celle de plus de 90 peut-être
95% de la population
après deux cent soixante ans de règne la
maison des valois branche cadette de la
dynastie capétienne doit céder le trône
à la maison des bourbons la france vient
de traverser plusieurs décennies d'une
guerre civile
impitoyable et pendant trente ans elle a
été dirigée par des rois jeunes
influençables
il s'agit des trois fils d'henri 2 et
catherine de médicis françois deux chars
le neuf et orrit 3 pour sortir des
dissensions religieuses qu'ils étouffent
le royaume a besoin d'un monarque fort
et fédérateur roi sans couronne henri iv
premier bourbon doit encore lutter
contre la ligue catholique véritable
contre-pouvoir politique et militaire
qui ne veut pas d'un protestant sur le
trône de france où seulement c'est un
hérétique
mais c'est ce qu'on appelle un relapse
c'est à dire quelqu'un qui a été
catholique une partie de sa vie et qui
est revenu à l'hérésie
donc c'est encore plus grave henri iv a
changé une bonne demi douzaine de fois
de religion entre sa naissance et 489 et
donc ils ajoutent à la casquette si
j'ose dire de l'hérétique calviniste du
disciple de calvin la casquette de celui
qui d'une certaine façon on n'a pas
vraiment de religion qui est capable
d'en changer et il l'a prouvé maintes
fois
[Applaudissements]
l'espagne est rom soutiennent la ligue
catholique dans sa guerre contre henri
iv ce dernier reçoit le soutien des
ennemis de l'espagne et des amis de la
réforme les calvinistes hollandais les
protestants d'allemagne les anglais et
les phéniciens ne veulent pas laisser le
pouvoir espagnol s'imposer en france
[Musique]
leroy paie de sa personne dans les
batailles spécialement à evry et c'est
un grand événement militaire qui va
entraîner le ralliement d'une partie de
soldats d'une partie de grand seigneur
qui voit désormais un peu le vent
tourner en faveur de ce roi pourtant
protestants le pape sixte quint qui a
excommunié henry en 15 100 85 comprend
que la sauvegarde du catholicisme romain
n'est pas la seule raison qui pousse le
roi philippe ii d'espagne à se mêler des
affaires de la france n'envisage donc la
conversion au catholicisme d'henri comme
la condition préalable à son
couronnement
enfin malgré la propagande de la ligue
catholique
la majorité des français supporte mal
l'ingérence de la monarchie espagnole et
préfère voir un français mais mary tic
ceindre la couronne le français lambda
se doute bien que l'invasion espagnole
pour regarder la couronne catholique
cache quelque chose que c'est un jeu
trouble c'est certain c'est interlope
c'est bien que philippe ii et son armée
d'espagnol n'est pas du tout du tout
bien apprécié sur le territoire c'est
donc dans ces circonstances que le roi
précipite les choses il décide de faire
le saut périlleux justement pour couper
court aux prétentions des autres princes
voir princesse à la couronne de france
c'est une conversion largement politique
[Musique]
ah ah
dans une
le
le 25 juillet 15 193 le roi à mesure la
religion réformée dans la basilique de
saint denis
le soir même le royaume est illuminé par
les innombrables feu de joie allumé par
une population en liesse
[Musique]
paris et reims sont encore aux mains de
la ligue ans le 4 est donc sacré à
chartres le 27 février 15 100 94
un mois plus tard le roi entre
triomphalement dans la capitale
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
henri iv est un roi soldats mais ce
n'est pas qu'un soldat c'est un
politique à ses fins qui s'est négociée
qui sait pardonner et qui s'est passé
des alliances avec ses anciens
adversaires et c'est ce qu'il fait en
particulier avec les villes ligneuse qui
se rallient il pardonne ou bien avec les
grands seigneurs catholique de la ligue
à qui il va également pardonner à qui il
va même donner des pensions des dons
assez important pour oublier le passé
une mène une politique de clémence qui
surprend d'ailleurs une politique de
clémence qui va être jugé comme inspiré
par dieu s'il s'emploie à maintenir la
paix à l'intérieur du royaume
henri iv entend punir l'espagne en
menant contre elle une guerre féroce
dans les années 15 995 15 198 ses
victoires militaires redore le prestige
du roi et unissons peuple derrière lui
pendant que les négociations de paix
avec l'espagne suivent leur cours
henri iv se tourner vers le problème
intérieur le plus urgent la
revendication de liberté religieuse des
protestants
avec la signature de l'édit de nantes le
13 avril 15 198 le roi mette un terme à
trente six ans de guerres de religion
qui ont épuisé le royaume les huguenots
sont amnistiés des crimes commis durant
la guerre civile
cet édit de tolérance reconnaît de
protestantisme et au nom de la liberté
de conscience autorise l'exercice du
culte réformé le modo qui pour nous est
devenu un mot très positif aujourd'hui
en fait tolérer c'est accepter du bout
des lèvres mais la majorité catholique
et le roi catholique tolère l'existence
d'églises protestantes sur le territoire
et pour donner plus de garanties aux
protestants contre des velléités de
reconquête par la force de la part du
catholicisme les protestants dispose
d'un certain nombre de places fortes qui
sont à eux qui sont payés par le trésor
royal mais dans lesquels il y a des
capitaines et les garnisons protestante
c'est ce qu'on appelle les places de
sûreté en somme les places qui les
garantissent henry cadre établi la
coexistence non violente de deux
confessions dont une est légitime et pas
l'autre mais il devient quand même grâce
à l'édit de nantes ce symbole ce
souverain symbole de l'exercice de la
tolérance et j'allais dire d'un pouvoir
politique qui parvient à imposer la
tolérance à des sujets partagé entre
deux confessions religieuses
pourtant lé dinh satisfait pleinement
aucune des deux factions l équilibre
demeure fragile
le roi a maintenant 46 ans et lorsqu'ils
tombent gravement malades
chacun se rend compte du cataclysme qui
s'abattrait sur le royaume
s'il venait à mourir sans héritier
depuis quinze 172 il est marié à
marguerite de valois la fille d'henri ii
et catherine de médicis les époux vivent
séparés chacun mène sa vie amoureuse de
son côté marguerite se montre favorable
au divorce
on cherche donc à henri iv une épouse
digne de son rang
mais le roi qu'on surnomme le vert
galant en référence à ses nombreuses
conquêtes féminines entend épouse et sa
maîtresse la belle gabrielle d'estrées
qui lui a déjà donné deux fils la course
indigne et marguerite de valois ne peut
consentir à laisser sa place à une fille
de basse naissance gabriel moeurs
opportunément le 10 avril 15 999 pour
sortir le roi de son chagrin
son entourage lui présente la jeune et
virginale henriette d'entragues filles
de marie touchait même ancien favorite
du roi charles neuf henri capt tombe
sous son charme et promet le mariage à
la belle au grand dam du principal
ministre sully
il s'empresse de déchirer une imprudente
lettre signée de la main du roi
la france sort exemple des guerres de
religion et doiteau médicis la somme
astronomique de 1 million 174 1147 écus
pour effacer une partie de l'ardoisé une
union stratégique se dessine alors entre
henri iv la princesse de toscane marie
de médicis en apprenant les négociations
du mariage henriette la nouvelle
favorite en titre entre dans une colère
noire que seul le don du marquisat de
verneuil parvient quelque peu apaisées
[Musique]
henri iv ne connaît pas encore sa future
épouse et il ne possède qu'un portrait
qui représente marie de médicis à l'âge
de 17 ans or elle en a aujourd'hui 27
ils profitent donc d'une mission confiée
à un émissaire à rome pour remercié le
pape d'avoir bien voulu annuler sa
première union avec marguerite de valois
et il leur donne à cet envoyé spécial de
passer par florence l'émissaire doit
observer avec soin la jeune femme et
faire son compte-rendu roi de retour au
louvre celui-ci ne tarit pas d'éloges
sur la physionomie majestueuse de la
princesse son teint clair
ses cheveux blonds sa poitrine généreuse
et son double menton qui sont des
charmes très apprécié dans les canons de
beauté de l'époque le 5 octobre 16 cents
à florence marie de médicis épouse henri
iv par procuration le contrat de mariage
prévoit une dot substantielle deux cent
cinquante mille écus payé par annulation
de créances et 350 mille écus pays
comptant la pieuse marie de médicis
incarne alors pour les catholiques
l'espoir de la reconquête des âmes quand
le mariage de henri iv avec marie de
médicis a été négocié ça a été sous
l'égide du pape et c'était un peu comme
un élément du pas de réconciliation
entre henri iv dont le pape se méfier
évidemment raison de son protestantisme
d'origine et puis la conversion au
catholicisme de henri iv et marie de
médicis s'est vu donner une mission par
le pape qui était en somme ma chère
princesse épousé le roi de france fait
lui beaucoup d'enfants bons catholiques
comme elle est assez nettement plus
jeune que henri iv il ya fort à parier
que même sans l'assassinât d'henri iv
elle va lui survivre avec l'assassinât
d'henri iv effectivement et lui survit
et donc tout son programme politique
c'est de pouvoir amarrer la france au
catholicisme et elle va s'y employer
dans ce but souverain pontife pris la
nouvelle reine de france de favoriser le
retour des 18 accusés d'avoir inspiré
l'attentât de jean chatel contre henri
iv en 15 100 94
ces derniers ont été banni du royaume de
france avant qu'elles n'embarquent pour
sa nouvelle patrie le grand duc ne cesse
de répéter à sa nièce
cette dernière recommandation soyez
enceinte
le 9 novembre c'est sans mari arrive à
marseille mais ce n'est qu'un mois plus
tard à lyon qu'elles rencontrent enfin
son époux pour la première fois le
mariage religieux est célébrée le 17
décembre
neuf mois plus tard le 27 septembre 16
cents 1 n'est le futur louis xiii mari
accomplisse sa mission en donnant un
dauphin à la france
c'est un événement et bien parce que
c'est un enfant mal c'est le la
descendance du roi qui est assuré et ça
stabilise si je puis dire l'avenir de la
dynastie des bourbons le bonheur
pourrait être complet si les frasques
amoureuses du fer galant nominés pas peu
à peu les relations au sein du couple
royal
alors évidemment pour marie de médicis
qui est une femme assez austère la vie
n'est pas drôle tous les jours parce que
d'abord il est 4 continue d'avoir des
maîtresses et puis surtout au vieux
château de saint germain mais bien il
fait cohabiter tout le monde tous les
petits bâtard qu'il a eu avec gabrielle
d'estrées avec ses enfants légitimes
tout le monde de vivre dans cette espèce
de garderie louis xiii ne supporte pas
le futur louis xiii qui est très austère
et très guindé ne supporte pas ses
petits frères batteur donc et marie
médicis et est très malheureuse ans est
dans ce cas de figure
marie de médicis poursuit la mission qui
lui a été confiée par le pape en
convainquant henri iv d'autoriser le
retour des jésuites en france des 604
henri iv se trouve à la tête d'un
royaume martyrisé kia dont la population
a stagné dont les ressources agricoles
ont baissé
le peuple est désabusé par toutes ces
années de privations par les pestes
également qu'ils ont marqué le roi doit
reconstruire son royaume
il va mener une politique fiscale
intelligente mais très ferme néanmoins
mais il ne faut pas cacher que cette
politique va provoquer un certain nombre
de révolte avec l'aide du duc de sully
principal ministre et grand
administrateur henri iv travaillent à
restaurer les finances et à réorganiser
efficacement le royaume habitué à la
fantaisie de la cour de toscane marie de
médicis des cours la rigidité de la
maison de la reine qui compte près de
500 serviteur c'est une petite société
vous et assurer la tradition du bon
service et chaque charge revient à une
famille qui sert la monarchie depuis des
générations
on peut dire qu'il y a ainsi de
véritables dynasties de serviteur c'est
antoinette de pons qui est la première
dame d'honneur de la reine est donc le
grand chef d'orchestre de cette
administration particulière on prête
d'ailleurs serment de fidélité entre ses
mains mais voilà marie de médicis est
arrivé avec sa suite italienne et elle
entend bien imposer son ami d'enfance
leonora daury la fameuse galigaï comme
dame d'atours bref on la marie à
continent comme chiny un homme l'italien
qui a aussi fait partie du voyage et
marie de médicis impose son ami à la
cour dans sa lutte acharnée pour
conquérir son trône
henri iv à nouer des alliances avec
l'angleterre en 16 103 et avec les
princes protestants allemands hans et
110 pour l'amour de sa nouvelle conquête
charlotte de montmorency il envisage
même d'entrer en guerre contre les
habsbourg
après les innombrables tentatives
d'assassinât fomentée contre lui et
l'épuisement causé par les guerres de
religion la santé du roi décline
laissant entrevoir la possibilité d'une
régence parler de médicis prêche en
faveur du sacre qui lui donnerait toute
la légitimité nécessaire au cas où le
roi viendrait à disparaître car le futur
louis xiii est encore mineur
le 13 mai c'est 110 marie de médicis et
sacré à saint denis avec tous les
honneurs
le lendemain 14 mai c'est 110 alors que
son carrosse empruntent la rue de la
ferronnerie à paris henri iv est
assassiné par un fanatique religieux
françois ravaillac
il laisse à son fils le jeune louis xiii
un royaume a grandi qui représente près
des quatre cinquièmes de la france
actuelle et compte une population
hétéroclite d'environ 12 millions de
sujets mais ce territoire est encore
désunie sur le plan religieux
le roi a remporté les guerres de
religion si l'on peut dire
il a pacifié son royaume mais il meurt
tragiquement en 1610 assassiné par
ravaillac
le choc est tellement fort les français
sont tellement effrayés ils ont
tellement peur que les guerres civiles
reprennent comme elles avaient eu lieu
pendant trente ans auparavant qu'ils
vont idéalisé assez rapidement la figure
de ce roi pacificateur de ce roi henry
qui a donné la paix au royaume de france
[Musique]
à la suite de cet assassinat un conseil
de régence avait été instituée mais le
testament de henri iv a été annulée et
la régence a été prise totalement en
main par sa veuve marie de médicis alors
marie de médicis naturellement n'est pas
la reine de france en exercice puisque
le souverain ne peut être qu'un homme en
france et ce souverain c'est
nécessairement le fils aîné de henri iv
qui prend le titre de louis xiii
mais louis xiii au moment de la mort de
son père à seulement de l'avant donc en
le proclame roi
et puis c'est donc le conseil de régence
qui va gouverner à sa place et ce
conseil de régence se réduit à sa mère
marie de médicis marie de médicis assume
pleinement l'exercice du pouvoir dans
une france où deux confessions
religieuses ont bien du mal à cohabiter
dans les mêmes provinces et les mêmes
parlement cette situation fragile et
veillent donc les ambitions des nobles
qui cherche a entamé l'autorité
monarchique
elle commence assez mal comme tout
régence par déjà une demande des grands
de participation au pouvoir après la le
règne ford quatrième sorte de
défoulement des grands le trône c'est
considéré comme une co propriété
familiale
l'idée de quelque chose qui est l'état
qui est évidemment quelque chose qui se
transmet avec certaines règles de
succession et c'est une idée qui nous
est familière aujourd'hui elle n'était
pas du tout familière aux gens de cette
époque on était dans un système on peut
dire complètement féodal par sa
conception dans lequel une famille une
famille élargie avec les cousins et
neveux les collatéraux et c'est une
famille est propriétaire donc d'un
bien du principauté ou d'un royaume
quand marie de médicis décide de se
faire proclamer seule la régente ça
provoque évidemment les grincements de
dents de tous les princes de la famille
royale qui considèrent qu'ils ont de
façon naturelle une part au gâteau pour
calmer les ardeurs des princes
la régente les couvre d'argent et de
bénéfices ans et 111 cette pratique
coûte près de 4 millions de livres à la
france la santé fragile de louis xiii
fait l'objet d'une surveillance
attentive et le jeune roy a subi des
traitements constants privé de tendresse
maternelle et souvent battue c'est un
enfant solitaire et mélancolique sa mère
qui le juge inapte à gouverner prend
d'ailleurs soin de le tenir à l'écart du
pouvoir
[Musique]
c'est surtout un enfant qui est très
antagoniste à la fois il peut se montrer
sociable par moments et deux de temps en
temps et bien il se retire pendant
pendant des jours et des jours et on ne
retrouve plus le petit gamin que non la
laissait auparavant
alors ça va donner forcément un roi
antagonistes si l'enfant était déjà le
roi le sera aussi
c'est un enfant un timide sans doute un
peu écrasée par la personnalité de son
père qu'il adore et qui de surcroît un
inconvénient il est bègue et il a une
certaine difficulté à s'affirmer
si la régente garde au gouvernement les
hommes d'henri iv tel sully ou villeroy
elle fait entrer nombre de prince au
conseil d'état qui devient une
institution lente inefficace elle doit
alors tenir des conseils officieux afin
de pouvoir prendre de réelles décisions
le principal ministre sully qui dirige
avec brio les finances royales la des
accusations de malversations démissionne
le 26 janvier ses 111
il laisse alors le champ libre à
l'ambitieux concino concini marié à la
protégée de la reine leonora c'est le
début du règne des favoris zidane
qu'on en finisse et en quelque sorte si
on peut dire le favori de marie de
médicis et qu'on finit est un intrigant
qui s'est emparée du pouvoir et qu'il a
exercé pendant la régence de marie de
médicis au grand déplaisir du jeune
louis xiii qui voulaient régner mais
avait beaucoup de mal à s'imposer devant
cet italien arrogant qui ne manquait pas
une occasion de l'humilier un non
seulement après la mort du roi hisser au
premier rang de la noblesse française
le couple concini et richissime
découvert de titres suscitant dès lors
bien des jalousies la galigaï use et
abuse de son influence sur marie de
médicis au louvre elle bénéficie même
d'un appartement qui communique avec
celui de la reine où on la trouve à
toute heure du jour ou de la nuit
la reine au pouvoir interrompre sitôt la
politique offensive comme né henri iv à
sa mort pour revenir à l'alliance
traditionnelle catholique avec l'espagne
la région de fait le choix de se
rapprocher des habsbourg l'autre
puissance catholique européenne tout son
programme politique c'est de pouvoir
amarrer la france au catholicisme et
elle va s'y employer
voilà alors c'est ça la toile de fond de
ce qui se passe en 1615 c'est à dire la
réalisation de ce qu'est le grand rêve
de marie de médicis probablement bien
avant qu'elle devienne régente mais à
partir du moment où elles et régente là
en tout cas sur le papier tous les
pouvoirs et ce grand rêve c'est ce que
on appellera à l'époque déjà le double
mariage l'espagnol
le double mariage espagnol prévoit
l'union de louis xiii avec anne
d'autriche fille du roi d'espagne
philippe iii et arrière petite fille de
l'empereur charles quint et l'union
d'elisabeth de france avec le frère dan
qui deviendra philippe iv en 16 121 en
accédant au trône d'espagne alors c'est
une visée politique tout à fait évidente
dans la politique que veut mener marie
de médicis ses assurés l'alliance avec
l'espagne c'est garantir en quelque
sorte la paix et la prorogation d'une
politique catholique au fond
d'application du concile de trente en
europe et pince français notamment les
protestants voit d'un mauvais oeil ce
rapprochement avec la très catholique
monarchie espagnole un certain nombre de
chefs du parti protestant dont plusieurs
appartiennent à la grande noblesse et
certains sont également de la famille
royale
car la famille royale c'est aussi divisé
les princes et qui porte le nom de condé
qui sont protestants et les princes de
condé évidemment se considèrent comme
les chefs naturel du parti protestant
évidemment à titre de prince et à titre
de chef protestant pas ils veulent je
dirais presque le double part de gâteau
évidemment on n'est pas très contents de
voir cette alliance avec l'espagne et
qui va de toute façon renfoncer la
monarchie ça c'est clair et une
monarchie trop puissante
évidemment ça le fait les affaires ni
des uns ni des autres et donc marie de
médicis pas avoir beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de difficultés à réaliser ce
mariage en janvier 714 pour montrer son
désaccord avec cette politique
condé quittent la cour suivi des duc de
nevers longueville du maine et de
bouillants
la régente doit faire face à une vague
de contestation si forte qu'elle est
obligé de convoquer les états généraux à
la reine qui n'est pas très assurée de
son pouvoir entend se faire conforté par
les trois ordres du royaume qu'elle
convoque donc en des états généraux qui
devraient normalement assuré son pouvoir
notamment face à condé face aux grands
qui lui réclament une participation à
l'autorité souveraine avant les états
généraux de 1789 les derniers états
généraux qui s'étaient réunis ce sont
ceux que marie de médicis a été obligé
de réunir en 1614 qui se sont plus ou
moins bien passé mais qui lui ont
finalement donné en tout cas une sorte
de brevets de tranquillité intérieure et
un blanc seing pour mener à bien malgré
quelques troubles les mariages espagnol
c'est aussi à l'occasion de ces états
généraux que se dessine le destin du
jeune évêque de luçon
remarqué par marie de médicis et qui
deviendra plus tard célèbre cardinal de
richelieu le 2 octobre 16 114 louis xiii
et déclarés majeurs par le parlement
après avoir remercié sa mère d'avoir si
bien administrer la france en son nom
ils déclarent prendre en charge le
gouvernement de son royaume
mais comme on le lui a demandé il nomme
marie de médicis chef de son conseil la
soif de pouvoir de concini déjà membre
du conseil d'état et des finances ne
cesse de grandir
28 novembre 715 louis xiii épouse anne
d'autriche à bordeaux
marie de médicis n'a qu'une idée en tête
pour être valide
il faut que ce mariage très politique
soit consommé le plus rapidement
possible c'est chose faite le soir même
mais cette expérience force et
traumatisent les jeunes époux
donc en 1615 triomphe de marie de
médicis malgré les grandes difficultés
malgré alors des difficultés qui la
tuera en coûte des vies humaines et qui
assèche complètement le trésor royal
parce que financer la guerre ça coûte
toujours très cher et acheter la paix
pour calmer les mécontentements et les
gourmandises ça coûte également très
très cher la région s'appuie de plus en
plus sur continue chaque jour plus
impopulaire il est conseiller d'état un
de marie de médicis donc il va
développer véritablement 7,7 cet élan ce
mouvement pro italien à la cour
c'est lui aussi qui va essayer
d'influencer marie et de médicis en
sous-main en souterrain contre louis
xiii
le comportement arrogant et ostentatoire
de concini attise la colère contre la
régence de marie de médicis en 716 une
rébellion conduite par condé éclate
contre le couple d'italiens condé et les
princes affrontent les factions de
concini pour accéder au pouvoir et vont
jusqu'à fomenter un projet d'assassinât
de l'encombrant favoris et d'éviction de
la reine mère cette dernière fait alors
arrêtez de prince le 1er septembre 16
116 mais l'impopularité du couple
d'italiens grandi au point que leurs
maisons et ravagé par le peuple tandis
que les conjurés se met en ordre de
bataille
richelieu nommé ministre des affaires
étrangères et de la guerre prépare
contre eux trois armées mais marie de
médicis ne voit pas le vent tourner
comme elle avait pris soin de nash et
auprès de son fils que des serviteurs
qu'elle jugeait de faible intelligence
la régente est loin de soupçonner que le
changement radical va naître de la
volonté de louis xiii
conseillé par son fauconnier et ami
charles de luynes le roi est enfin prêt
à prendre son destin en main
la réaction de louis xiii
elle a été celle du timide qui veut
s'imposer qui finalement excédé a
ordonné l'assassinât de concini pour
parvenir lui même à prendre le pouvoir
avec son assentiment les partisans de
louis xiii fomente un assassinat 24
avril 16 117 concini devenue maréchale
tombent dans une embuscade en arrivant
au louvre et il est poignardée à mort
les juges du parlement de paris a vu son
épouse la galigaï de sorcellerie et la
condamne à être décapité après ce coup
de majesté la reine mère est contrainte
à l'exil au château de blois
[Musique]
le choc de cette brutale éviction est
terrible pour marie de médicis assigné à
résidence au château de blois ses
moindres gestes sont épiés et rapporter
à luynes le nouveau favori en titre qui
conseille louis xiii dans sa gouvernance
pour brider le caractère intrigant de la
reine déchue
les rares visites qu'on lui accorde son
contrôle est déjà privé de barben son
fidèle attendant prisonniers à la
bastille c'est au tour de richelieu
d'être renvoyé dans son évêché de lui
son mari ne cessent d'assurer le roi de
sa complète soumission et le prix de la
laisser revenir au conseil mais
l'impérieux louis xiii reste de marbre
devant les supplications de cette mère
qui lui a témoigné si peu d'affection
jusqu'à présent
louis xiii libéré de la pesante tutelle
de sa mère
boot enfin au plaisir d'être un roi
souverain alors lui nommé au point un
stratagème très élaborée qui consiste à
laisser
barbin l'ex intendant de marie de
médicis qui est emprisonné à la bastille
correspondre avec la reine exilé à blois
ce qui avait été interdite par louis
xiii luynes se débrouille pour faire
recopier les lettres avant qu'elle ne
parvienne à leurs destinataires et en
1618 alors que l'opinion publique
commence à pencher en faveur de marie de
médicis qui est comme prisonnière alors
que dans l'esprit des français
son rôle est d'être auprès du roi lui ne
présente la copie de cette
correspondance accompagné de
considérations alarmistes sur la
sécurité du trône dans ce climat de
suspicion
l'étau se resserre autour de marie de
médicis qui subit une surveillance de
plus en plus étroite
elle est menacée d'être expulsée du
royaume si elles ne renoncent pas à
toute action politique
mais l'opinion public gronde contre lui
et lorsque marie comprend que cet exil
est vouée à durer
poussée par son entourage ultra
catholique elle décide se posera son
fils par les armes le 22 février 719 la
reine s'évade du château de blois
elle sera de se sauver dans les
conditions rocambolesques en descendant
d'une fenêtre avec une corde
le très catholique duc d'epernon
lieutenant général des armées se rallie
à marie de médicis suivi du duc de
bouillon et du prince de lorraine
c'est le début d'une première guerre
entre la mère et le fils qui s'achève le
30 avril 16 119 avec la signature du
traité dont glen
face à elle la reine mère ne retrouve
pas cette enfant craintif mais le digne
fils d'henri iv louis xiii victorieux
pardonne mais comme il refuse à sa mère
son rétablissement conseil royal une
deuxième guerre éclate en juillet 16
s'en va marie de médicis et mises en
déroute c'est tout
lors de la bataille des ponts de cé
trois jours plus tard le traité danger
met fin à cette deuxième guerre entre la
mère et le fils
[Musique]
le 14 décembre 721 la mort de luynes
laisse de nouveau le champ libre à marie
de médicis
l'année suivante richelieu devient
cardinal et prêchent pour un apaisement
des relations entre la mère et le fils
alors elle rentre à paris les elle est
d'accord se dit c'est promis je ne me
mêle plus de votre politique c'est
entendu et puis elle va protéger les
arts et lettres parce que elle est quand
même très cultivée elle va créer
véritablement c'est elle qui découvrent
ce merveilleux peintre qu'elle va
protéger son punk et rubens rubens va
tout à marie de médicis
elle construit son palais parisien qui
est aujourd'hui le palais du sénat c'est
un palais du luxembourg dans lesquelles
il ment dans lequel on connaît les
toiles merveilleuse et fresques de
rubens rubens réalise un cycle de 24
tableaux relatant la vie de la
souveraine sur un mode allégoriques et
mythologiques
le peintre représente l'arrivée de la
reine à marseille ou encore la
réconciliation entre la mère et le fils
ses oeuvres monumentales sont
aujourd'hui exposées au musée du louvre
à paris cet évêque de richelieu qui est
entre temps est devenu cardinal est
entré à l'intérieur du gouvernement
animé dirigée par louis xiii bon c'est
un homme d'église et il est très
favorable dans les premières années à
l'espagne et puis petit à petit il
évolue richelieu fait son entrée au
conseil royal richelieu d'un homme
moderne louis xiii est un roi qui a
envie de laisser sa trace dans
l'histoire
forcément ils ne peuvent travailler
ensemble
le ministére ya c'est un couple sans
plaisir
louis xiii a compris que richelieu avait
une intelligence qui lui étaient
nécessaires
il l'a tolérée auprès de lui il l'a
soutenu
il l'a maintenu au pouvoir mais on ne
peut pas dire qu'il y ait eu une grande
affinité entre les deux personnages
c'est une alliance politique qui
témoignent d'ailleurs de l'intelligence
et de la complémentarité des deux
personnages louis xiii endosse alors la
politique préconisée par son ministre
est alors qu il combat les huguenots à
l'intérieur du royaume pour affirmer
l'indépendance de la france à l'égard de
l'espagne
ils s'éloignent progressivement des
habsbourg en subventionnant secrètement
leurs ennemis protestants durant la
guerre de trente ans commencée en 118
alors c'est une politique assez
étonnante parce que louis xiii est
certainement le roi le plus dévots le
plus catholique que la france ait eu
c'est le premier des dévots du royaume
et il ne va malgré tout pas hésité à
s'allier avec des puissances protestante
pour simplement s'affirmer comme le
premier roi d'europe et sa seule chance
en politique extérieure c'est de
s'allier avec les puissances protestante
à commencer par la suède qui est la
nouvelle étoile militaire montante en
europe pour s'imposer face à ce couple
formidable qui enserre le royaume de
france
l'empiré l'espagne les habsbourg
d'espagne d'autriche rêve d'établir la
jonction entre leur territoire
l'espagne convoite l'italie du nord
région stratégique dans l' équilibre des
pouvoirs car elle sert de lien entre les
habsbourg d'autriche et les habsbourg
d'espagne
cela signifierait alors l'encerclement
de la france et consacrerait la
suprématie habsburg sur le théâtre
européen
mais ce revirement politique irrite
marie de médicis qui a tant oeuvré en
faveur du rapprochement franco espagnole
marie de médicis qui a toujours été le
point de référence du camp très
catholique et la stature elle a la
volonté un peu de régenter d'autant plus
qu'en europe il a une position tout à
fait extraordinaire elle est la mère du
roi de france
elle est la mère de la reine d'espagne
une autre de ses filles a épousé le roi
d'angleterre donc elle est la mère de la
reine d'angleterre
une autre de ses filles a épousé le duc
de savoie qui est prince de piedmont bon
c'est pas un roi mais c'est presque
endroit
la principauté de savoie piémont est
extrêmement importante en europe
l'impopularité de richelieu grandit à
mesure que son pouvoir s'affirme à la
tête de l'état marie de médicis
s'insurge contre l'évolution de la
politique française
elle n'est pas seule il ya beaucoup de
catholiques obscures ou puissants qu'ils
aident et en continu et tous les gens
qui ne supportent pas le pouvoir de
richelieu
évidemment tout ce monde là seul hic et
on profite de l'état de santé très
précaire de louis xiii qui est à
plusieurs reprises au seuil de la mort
mais profite des moments où il va très
mal pour faire pression sur lui on étant
évidemment marie de médicis en
particulier faire pression sur lui pour
qu'il chasse les curieux et qu'il change
de politique marie de médicis
sûr de sa légitimité va leur poser un
étrange ultimatum à louis xiii lors de
la fameuse journée des dieux c'est le
jour où marie de médicis par qui
richelieu est arrivé au pouvoir se rend
compte que sa créature richelieu mène
auprès du roi une politique qui n'est
plus la politique catholique d'alliance
avec l'espagne qu'elle souhaitait mais
que richelieu pousse le roi attaqué l'an
pire elle va donc provoquer une entrevue
avec son fils louis xiii où elle va
demander la tête de richelieu louis xiii
ne chasse pas richelieu et louis xiii a
même une phrase très extraordinaire un
des moments les plus dramatiques de ces
événements lorsqu'il dit entre mon état
et ma mère je choisis mon état
c'est quelque chose de très nouveau et
ça paraît complètement scandaleux pour
une grande partie de l'opinion publique
de l'époque
comment est-ce qu'on peut désavouer sa
mère alors pourquoi la journée des dupes
c'est un bon mot du bel esprit qui était
l'ambassadeur bolt rue à la cour qui a
dit qu'ils sont les du bassin les
courtisans qui dans un premier temps
croyant que marie de médicis
avait gagné la partie se sont précipités
en foule autour d'elle et puis quand ils
ont vu que le roi la lâchait pour
richelieu se sont immédiatement détourné
marie de médicis qui ne peut pardonner à
richelieu lui adresse ses mots assassins
vous êtes le plus ingrat des hommes j'ai
fait votre grandeur vous étiez de ma
maison j'ai demandé au roi de vous faire
cardinal de vous faire entrer dans son
conseil
je vous ai donné des places des charges
de l'or vous manqué aujourd'hui au
devoir de fidélité la rade maire qui
refuse de se plier à la volonté royale
est alors éloigné des affaires et exilé
à compiègne dès février c'est 131
[Musique]
gaston d'orléans fils cadet de marie de
médicis et agents de tous les complots
contre son frère louis xiii fédéral
heures autour de lui les ennemis de
richelieu afin de libérer sa mère de sa
captivité à compiègne une ligue des
gendres se met en place
elle essaye de récupérer tout ce tous
ces gens qui ont épousé tel ou tel de
ses filles soit en espagne soit ailleurs
pour monter manière de ligue contre
louis xiii et marie de médicis va finir
pas s'enfuir du château de compiègne et
se réfugier dans les pays bas espagnols
elle ne travaillait pas la france elle
est chez sa fille la reine d'espagne qui
l'accueille très volontiers plus tard
elle passera en angleterre chez sa fille
la reine d'angleterre
mais à partir de cet exil volontaire
exil de la france elle mène une campagne
forcenée contre richelieu
c'est à dire aussi contre louis xiii en
finançant des complots en finançant des
campagnes de presse etc et elle
reviendra jamais en france quand ils
passent la frontière en juillet 631
marie de médicis disparaît de la scène
politique française
sans se douter qu'elle ne reviendra
jamais dans ce royaume qui fut le sien
[Musique]
dans les années qui suivent les
relations demeurent glaciales entre la
mère et le fils marie apprend même la
naissance de son petit fils le futur
louis xiv en 16 138 par voie publique ou
trajets ne prend pas la peine d'envoyer
un émissaire pour féliciter louis xiii
la reine-mère se trouve désormais à
cologne et prend part à une nouvelle
conspiration contre louis xiii celle
fomenté par 5 mars la dernière d'une
longue série pour l'orgueilleuse marie
de médicis qui salue une fois de plus à
gaston d'orléans et à l'espagne
mais le complot est bien vite déjoué par
richard marie de médicis rend l'âme le 3
juillet 16 140 2 après avoir passé sa
vie à intriguer contre son fils dans
l'espoir de revenir au pouvoir
richelieu sa créature devenu son ennemi
intime lui survivra seulement cinq mois
l'histoire conserve un jugement sévère à
l'égard de cette reine qui avait été
vendu pour rattacher la france au
catholicisme et renflouer les caisses du
royaume
elle est pourtant à son fils louis xiii
un royaume intacte la france que louis
xiii et richelieu léguerons à louis xiv
via la régence d'anne d'autriche assisté
de mazarin cette france là elle est
devenue la première puissance européenne
c'est quand même un assez beau bilan
les choeurs d'henri iv et marie de
médicis sont transportés au prytanée
militaire de la flèche
fondée par le roi en 16 104 et disposés
de part et d'autre de l'hôtel oui mais
en 93 1793
quand les révolutionnaires ont tenu leur
réunion politique dans cette chapelle du
prytanée de la flèche et bien le général
fabre fonds qui présidait la réunion
d'hier on ne va pas de libérer devant
les vestiges de la monarchie brûlé moi
c'est coeur et on a placé ses choeurs
sur une manière de barbecue et c'est la
première fois dans l'histoire qu'ils ont
brûlés ensemble